[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance in Donald Trump's America if
you go over-the-top and fantasize about
an act of violence against him he and
those speaking for him declare that you
are evil that you have injured his
teenage son that your livelihood must be
destroyed if he goes over the top and
fantasizes about an act of violence he
offers no explanation he offers no
apology he offers no promise that he
will ever stop doing this he offers no
awareness that he is doing exactly the
same thing about which he plays the
victim in Donald Trump's America if
somebody has hijacked and sabotage your
religion or your heritage or your skin
color he and those speaking for him
declare that you are nevertheless a
threat you are automatically guilty
anyway you are a terrorist if his own
people do that he will never say they
are a threat he will never say they are
automatically guilty he will never say
they are terrorists in Donald Trump's
America if you have a television program
that is not about politics and if you
have a Twitter account not affiliated
with that program or the network that
carries it and you dare to call him out
on it as a racist he and though speaking
for him will declare a quote untruths
will demand an apology from your
employer will insist you should be fired
if he does that if he calls the
president a racist from a Twitter
account not affiliated with his show nor
the network that carried it he will not
even remember he did it the president
behaves like a dictator with no interest
in the First Amendment nor the
Constitution nor free speech we know
that the president behaves like a white
supremacist - even when given a series
of passes for his own appalling sympathy
for the Nazis and the KKK he must tear
those passes up and default back to the
public statements mitigating their
horror and their hatred we know that the
president behaves like a man with little
or no control over his own violent
fantasies this dream of hitting a golf
ball hard enough off Hillary Clinton's
back to cause her to collapse it's just
the latest there was that wrestling
against the media the taunting of an
unstable foreign leader waiting for an
excuse to start a war the encouragement
of violence against others during his
campaign the [ __ ] grabber tape violence
and misogynistic violence and sexual
violence are in this man's soul we know
that but perhaps even in the context of
these nightmare realities that there's
not just a person like this who is not
in a home somewhere but that this person
has seized power and is erasing our
democracy day by day even considering
that horror we may have missed the true
overarching point of Donald Trump's
America which is simply this if
something is done to Trump he has been
wronged he is a victim he is under
attack but if the same exact thing is
done by Trump it's fine or you are
overreacting or America has enough of
political correctness or you don't have
a right to say it
Donald Trump is a human double standard
of all the existential perils he
presents to our country at our lives
none may be worse than this for 200
years we have defeated those who would
turn free speech off and on like a light
switch for 50 years we had beaten back
the racists and the anti-semites for 30
years we have suppressed the misogynists
in the sexist for 20 years we have begun
to push back against the violent and the
bullies and those who excuse violent
fantasies and bullying is simply another
aspect of expression or their culture
but now Trump has indicated to all of
those people all of these vermin all of
these scum that what is wrong with them
the need to silence others they need to
hate blacks and Jews and almost any
group to which they do not personally
belong the need to treat women as
chattel the need to be violent or to
fantasize about violence he has
essentially told them that not only is
it not wrong anymore not only that they
can do all these things with his
permission but that they alone can do
all these things and
is the slightest response the slightest
fighting of a Charlottesville fire with
fire the slightest pursuit of justice
they may pretend as if they have been
oppressed and if they have been victims
and if they have become martyrs if it is
done by Trump or by extension if it is
done by these dysfunctional cretins the
rest of American society has tolerated
for decades it is free speech and
justice and make America great again if
it is done to trump or by extension if
it is done to those still too stupid to
see he is conning them it is treason and
untruth and it is disseminated by the
quote enemy of the American people the
human double standard is in the White
House the creator of racial division and
untruth in this country is in the White
House the enemy of the American people
is in the White House and his removal
can no longer wait resist remove peace